What do you suggest for small lesions or tumors in the lungs?
So
tumors or lesions in the lungs. So understand the terminus radiologist looks at a CT skin or an MRI or an x-ray
They call an abnormality. They'll call a lesion. So a lesion is just a terminology
The use to there's an abnormality. We don't know what it is yet
The the terminology of difference between a tumor and a cancer is
Symmantics really because
In the old days, you could say a cancer was a very awful call the tumor. So I have a breast tumor. That's typically they were
breast cancer
Now the terminology has morphed a little bit and tumor is more
Don't not always but it's more commonly used with a benign lesion
It you'd say a tumor
The correct terminology is when you don't know what something is it's called a lesion and the correct terminology
When you biopsy it and it is not
Malignant it is not cancerous. It would be called a buddhined tumor
So it wouldn't just call it a tumor. You call it a buddhined tumor
But while things haven't been biopsy prior to them being biopsy so they're
viewed on
Imaging of some sort whether it be an ultrasonic MRI
CT scan
A PET scan or something else then they would be called a lesion
so
The question what do you do suggests for a small lesion or tumor in the lungs?
Well partly it depends on what it is so if it has been ruled out
The a biopsy so that it is known to be benign
Then the the answer to that could be very different versus its
Thought to be and we didn't do a biopsy on it yet, but it's thought to be a metastatic
lesion that's the testercise from my breast cancer, let's say so if I have breast cancer and now I'm showing lesions in the lung
well to good chance that it's
If those lesions weren't there prior on any scans, it's a good chance that their metastatic it's metastatic cancer
From the breast and what would you do in that case you would continue to treat the cancer?
So the things that you're doing for your breast cancer would be the same things that you're doing for that cancer in the lungs because
You know, again when something metastasizes from its primary site
It's still that same cancer if I have breast cancer metastasized the lung it's still breast cancer that lung cancer so
So number one you would treat it as the cancer if you know it's the cancer number two you treat it as the cancer if you
Have a pretty skilled sneaking suspicion that's the cancer and you don't want to biopsy it to fight down
So you'd still treat it as the cancer. What are some other things that a person could do knowing that they have metastasis to the lung
you could
You could do
Nebulized therapy because you could get cancer. You could get at the tumor
More directly so you say nebulized kind of your proxied we have that protocol that dr. Bacola's nebulized
Hydrogen peroxide protocol on the faith page
Home page of the member site so I'd tell you to go back to that and
And do we deputalized
I think the proxied therapy that would be a smart thing to do
Then you know do we deputalized colloidal silver would be another possible thing to do whatever you have the
Cancer at us bought where you could possibly get at it. You try to take advantage of those kind of things
So the other way to answer this question is that if a person didn't have cancer or they know
That's that cancer has been ruled out, but they just have lesions or tumors and lungs again
You'd still be looking at one of the cause of those trying to get rid of those
Causes and lesions in the lung can be infections causes of lesions and lungs can be
fun guy
Ask for jealous type things like that
And try to deal with those specific causes